hi I'm Steve Jobs every once in a while
a revolutionary product comes along that
changes everything today we're
introducing three revolutionary products
of this class and I would like to take
the privilege of showing you what
they're going to look like but before we
get to that I want to go back to
nineteen seventy-seven Apple a young
fledgling company on the west coast
invents the Apple to the first personal
computer as we know it today IBM
dismisses the personal computer as too
small to do serious computing and
unimportant to their business 1984 now
I'd like to show you Macintosh in person
they were American drug in 2001 the
choice we made was music now why music
well we love music and it's always good
to do something you love and that
product is called ipod today Apple is
going to reinvent the phone you've got
to see this thing in person but I'll do
the best I can with video this is imac
the whole thing is translucent you can
see into it it's so cool and we'd like
to show it to you today for the first
time and we call it the ipad that's what
it looks like very thin it's so thin it
even fits inside one of these envelopes
that we've all seen floating around the
office
this is the new macbook air a few weeks
ago we announced a user downloaded the
three billion 'the application from the
app store now something very exciting
it's my pleasure today to announce Mac
OS
there's an old Wayne Gretzky quote that
I love I skate to where the puck is
going to be not where it has been and
we've always tried to do that at Apple
since the very very beginning and we
always will so thank you very very much
but we're not done yet because I'd like
to let Macintosh speak for itself so it
is with considerable pride that I
introduce a man who's been like a father
to lead speed
you